bonjour ici c'est ce type kaufmann de
linguistes point com qu'est-ce que ces
deux limites points comme pour moi
d'abord linguistes c'est quelqu'un qui
parle qui sait parler plusieurs langues
au moins deux langues sa langue
maternelle et une autre langue c'est
quelqu'un qui s'intéresse aux langues je
crois que il ya beaucoup de personnes au
monde qui pourraient devenir des
linguistes
moi j'ai pris dix langues
ça m'a apporté beaucoup dans ma vie et
j'ai appris en apprenant ces langues
comment il faut apprendre les langues g
je me suis rendu compte que pour avoir
du succès dans l'apprentissage d'une
langue il faut avoir du plaisir il faut
aimer en rayon il trop souvent dans les
écoles les langues sont enseignés d'une
façon que décourage qui décourage les
apprenants souvent mettre l'accent sur
les explications de grammaire sur la
correction de textes etc alors ce qu'il
faut faire c'est il faut s'accoutumer à
la langue il faut beaucoup écouter et
beaucoup lire il faut surtout apprendre
des mots et les expressions alors ici à
de l'église points comme on a beaucoup
de ressources qu'on a beaucoup de
fichiers sonores et de textes dans
plusieurs langues et vous pouvez
prendre votre temps visiter notre
bibliothèque écouter et lire
ensuite il ne suffit pas évidemment
juste d'écouter de lire parce qu'il faut
méthode efficace justement pour acquérir
vocabulaire est ce que c'est ça qui est
un pas important c'est pour ça que nous
avons créé un un autre site lié à des
groupes qui s'appelle link elle y
injecter point com alors là il y a
beaucoup de fonctionnalités qui va vous
aider à prendre les mots et les
expressions
d'ailleurs qui va mesurer
calculer les mots et les expressions que
vous apprenez et en suit va vous aider à
choisir du contenu qui est à peu près à
votre niveau ce qui rend la tâche plus
facile et plus agréable en même temps
une fois que vous allez
vous aurez acquis beaucoup de mots et
d'expressions vous allez vouloir parler
et vous exprimer et là aussi alain vous
pouvez le faire on va corriger le texte
écrit qui on va aussi
indiqué les mots et les expressions que
vous ne l'utilisez pas exactement comme
le ferait le leur dif là vous pouvez
ensuite importer ses mots pour ensuite
les étudier vous allez voir aussi à
linky à toute une communauté de membres
partout au monde qui crée du contenu
très charmant et très intéressant dans
leur langue maternelle est écrit l'ordre
qu'ils offrent aux autres membres de la
communauté donc c'est tout un système
d'apprentissage des langues qui est
agréable tout donne du plaisir et qui
est très efficace donc j'espère que vous
allez prendre votre temps ici à dà nang
8 points comme et que vous allez aussi
allés visiter link vous pouvez vous
inscrire à inscrire gratuitement
et je vous souhaite de bonnes études et
que voilà et que tout le monde va
devenir un linguiste merci beaucoup au
revoir